[Music]
as an entrepreneur focus is critical
especially with the platform technology
one often knows that you can go after
many different product applications but
you ultimately get valued most
importantly on the first application you
bring forward and as an entrepreneur you
have limited time and limited resources
so you need to choose well and drive
deep into clinical and regulatory
validation for that first product now in
order to make that often really painful
decision about what to invest in and
what to leave on the side at least for a
while there's many aspects of of a
certain product you need to think
through obviously market size plays a
role technical fit to need plays a role
as I'm looking at new ideas I often try
to follow some the advice I once got
from Bob Langer who has been very
prolific he's started roughly 50
companies out of his lab I think at this
point and I've had the honor of starting
two companies with him among the other
kind of rules of the road he shares is
first look for a platform company if
you're gonna build a company make sure
that if you're successful in one area it
can create value in a number of adjacent
areas because that really justifies
bringing in the investment building the
whole infrastructure not just for one
product but potentially for many but
within that it's crucially important and
perhaps most important to select an
opportunity that has a very clearly
defined first product opportunity that
you have the ability to drive to a major
value creation event like a regulatory
or clinical approval as you're building
a business you ultimately get valued on
that lead asset you're carrying forward
so it's important to have a platform but
not to lose focus within that platform
and make one crucial bet that ultimately
can drive you a success of your company
what really gets me excited is
developing new therapies that can help
patients in order to do that you need to
think through who exactly is the patient
you're trying to help what disease do
they have and what kind of clinical
trial could you design that really
proves that you're giving a benefit to
that class of patient when you do that
you have to think through what type of
therapy is practical how is it given how
frequently and by whom
and in order to understand that whole
pathway from basic discovery to
delivering an actual therapeutic
requires a great variety of different
skills you must bring together and early
in our startups what we've done is first
focused on some of the fundamental
biology but then defined who are the
experts along the way that we're going
to need to engage in order to advance
all the way through the development
regulatory and clinical process and I
can't encourage young innovators enough
to think about engaging product
development experts and clinical experts
early in the discovery process because
that really shapes what you're trying to
discover and what you're trying to
create that can ultimately help the
patient as I interact with a lot of
young entrepreneurs who are thinking of
starting companies the most important
piece of advice I like to give them
particularly on the technical side is
find someone who has totally different
skills from you that you can trust and
will challenge you it can help you think
through the many aspects it takes to
address to build a business or create a
new therapy for me this was when Bob
Langer introduced me to David Luchino
who in 2005 became my co-founder of my
first startup and he took me out of the
lab dragged me into the hospital and
really started meeting nurses and
purchasers and doctors who are people
had never really interacted with at a
deep level so I could start to
understand if we're to develop a new
product who are all the stakeholders
this product would need to satisfy and
how can I understand all of their
incentives all of their constraints
because ultimately to get a new product
to patients you need to understand the
whole delivery system it's must go
through in order to bring that forward
and who must become champions and the
only way that was going to happen is by
that early interaction in introduction
to David who brought a business and
marketing and totally different
background but we challenged each other
we have mutual respect and it's let us
build now two businesses that have
brought a number of exciting things into
the clinic in order to enter this
industry particularly as an entrepreneur
as a first timer and that was straight
out of grad school I went into my first
startup and really had no experience
developing products I the advice I'd
give is really to engage people who've
gone through that product development
experience very early on they'll have a
lot of rules of the road a lot of
mistakes to avoid and can really help
make you successful even if you don't
have the deep domain experience yet and
it's amazing how much young
entrepreneurs who have a passion and
enthusiasm and some really big ideas can
engage and draw in people who have deep
experience even before potentially they
could afford them as consultants or
employees I think as entrepreneurs are
dreaming big you can share that energy
share that vision get people involved
and really bring in fantastic folks at a
very early stage one lesson that was
imparted to me early and in my previous
startup was to think very critically
about all the testing and all the
features that a medical device must go
through to be successful we were
essentially creating a new technology to
try to make medical devices safer
reducing clots or infection was
ultimately our goal for devices that
went into the body now we thought
initially as technologists about the new
feature we are creating and how powerful
it was and how helpful it could be but
as we started to work with experienced
product developers they made us realize
that these devices were designed with a
certain application in mind they needed
to perform certain functions first and
foremost and as we're adding our new
technology as we're making our advance
we couldn't do any harm to the current
standard of care as we're adding new
features onto an existing product and
that even applies in therapeutics
thinking about not in any way following
short of the standard of care in some
aspects as you're trying to improve
another aspect is very important and
experienced product developers can
really help you understand that process
in order to drive new innovative
medicines to the clinic a critical
aspect of this is developing a strong
intellectual property position because
of the great resources required to
advance a medicine it can be hundreds of
millions of dollars to advance from
concept through trials and even billions
of dollars before ultimate launch of a
product in order to justify those kinds
of investments one needs to be able to
have a product that one can protect for
a period of time on the market the
benefits of the patent system are
essentially it's a trade for a period of
time
you're granted that right to be able to
have exclusive access to sell a certain
medicine but in trade for that
essentially have to disclose to the
world here's exactly how we did it and
it can let the world start thinking
pretty quickly about how can they do
better and at the end of the day whole
fields of science advanced new medicines
move forward and as things become
generic things continue medicines
continue to reach a broader and broader
patient population
[Music]